la montée des extrêmes en france mais
aussi maintenant en allemagne avec l'afd
angoisses nos amis allemands
il ya chez eux une mémoire collective
qui est la mémoire des années 30 il ya
surtout une culpabilité ou en tout cas
le désir que ne recommence jamais les
atroces dérives qui ont amené au nazisme
et il y a la conviction qu'il faut tout
faire par l'europe pour que jamais on ne
retrouve la menace du nationalisme comme
disait mitterrand
oui le nationalisme c'est la guerre
irako mangala dire qu'elle peut
contribuer à ce combat contre le front
national aujourd'hui on faisait lanvaux
en faisant en sorte que l'europe soit
une europe forte
ancré dans ses valeurs il s'agit pas
pour elle j'imagine de s'immiscer dans
le débat politique
on a pu y est ici lutte contre le fn
c'est ce qu'elle dit on verra comment
elle fait mais je ne crois pas que ce
soit tellement ça mais c'est surtout
faire en sorte de convaincre à nouveau
que l'europe et la réponse est la
solution et qui j'ai joué je pense que
si elle fait ça c'est aussi parce
qu'elle voit que les populismes
justement ne sont pas un privilège
triste privilège français elle voit
quand notre île et ses voisins et braque
autriche à la présidentielle au premier
tour le candidat il faudra fait 35% elle
voit life des montées et enfants que je
pense qu'il est nécessaire en effet que
les pro-européens alice et pourquoi pas
ensemble moi de ce point de vue là je ne
suis pas totalement choqués ou je ne
suis pas choqué parce que je pense que
il ya des valeurs communes que nous
devons défendre
il ya des combats européen ou
paneuropéen il ya les partis qui sont
des partis européens
il y a des valeurs qui sont des valeurs
européennes le combat européen contre le
front national en france à un combat
européen contre le populisme dont la
forme française et le front national
oui et de la même façon que pour ma part
je surveille de près ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays
j'ai le souhait et j'ai la conviction
que le royaume uni restera dans une
europe unie parce que c'est l'intérêt du
royaume uni parce que c'est l'intérêt de
l'europe parce que toute autre solution
serait perdante pour les uns est
perdante pour les autres et donc ça ne
se produira la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il n'aura pas échappé
marie le pen comme à tout le monde de le
re unis n'était pas la france
nous nous sommes un pays fondateur de
l'union européenne nous nous sommes un
pays pour laquelle pour lequel la
construction européenne a été construite
c'est bien la réconciliation
franco-allemande qui est là il nous
enfin nous sommes un pays coeur de la
zone euro nous avons non seulement en
commun c'est pas union européenne si on
dévoilait en internat aussi l'euro et
les français dont je vois même vraiment
avec inquiétude la montée du sentiment
eurosceptique chez eux
les français savent que le rôle et
protège et les défend et les français
sont attachés
quand on regarde les paramètres on le
voit attachés à l'euro dont marine le
pen se trompent les français ne voteront
jamais contre l'europe les français
n'iront jamais pour une sortie de l'euro
ce que nous devons faire nous les
pro-européens c'est simplement mieux
montrer en quoi il y a des solutions
européennes qui sont positives pour les
citoyens de ce pays
1 je considère que le principe d'une
négociation commerciale entre les états
unis l'europe ne doit pas être écartée
car cela peut-être d'intérêt commun un
bon type nous permettrait permettrait à
l'europe de s'ouvrir les marchés
américains et soyons conscients que les
marchés américains sont aujourd'hui plus
fermé que les marchés européens donc je
ne dis pas fermons la nouvelle région et
par grille assure ensuite je les dis il
faut que ce soit un bon type aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas d'accord nous avons des
négociations qui ne sont pas si opaque
que ça d'ailleurs et la commission
veille
est ce que tous les états membres soient
informés au fur et à mesure de la façon
dont joue ça tente de document et ma
collègue comment 7e 1 seront très
souvent devant le parlement vient
naturellement il ya une information qui
est fait mais aujourd'hui il faut que
cette négociation progresse et elle
n'est pas un stade qui permettent de
conclure un accord un car cela a été dit
et par françois hollande et par matthias
fekl et par d'autres
nous ne voulons pas d'une d'un accord
qui compromettrait donne
environnementale qui comprennent des
prêts aux normes sanitaires qui mettrait
en cause l'existence de notre
agriculture ou qu'ils ne permettraient
pas l'accès aux marchés publics
voilà un certain nombre de conditions
donc sur le principe nous nous opposons
pas la négociation doit être conduite de
manière extrêmement serré et solide en
fonction de nos intérêts stratégie est
ce que c'est possible aujourd'hui est ce
que là est ce que les états unis ne
cherchent pas à imposer leur point de
vue comme disent les détracteurs à
mettre l'europe sous tutelle moi j'ai
pris un petit peu de recul avec
certaines passions nationales et
j'imagine que si j'étais américain et je
voyais le document européen
je me dirais non européens ils ont plein
les yeux rougis ne veulent pas nous
aider nous comprennent pas c'est le
propre d'une négociation et donc moi je
suis pas très choqué par le fait que
aujourd'hui les deux parties ne soit pas
vraiment en train de se rencontrer mais
l'europe
premier point la vente le principe ne
gardons pas deuxième fois il faut un bon
type il faut beaucoup de conditions et
troisième point ces conditions
aujourd'hui ne sont pas remplies la
question qui est nous devons nous c'est
la question du temps parce qu'il reste
peu de temps pour conclure
éventuellement ce type puisque vous
savez que l'administration américaine
reid celle de barack obama s'achève
début novembre
donc voilà le compte à rebours est très
serré et quand le président dit
aujourd'hui ce serait non
je suis d'accord aujourd'hui on n'y est
pas je veux le dire différemment mais il
faut en même temps que les négociations
se poursuivent que le travail c'est en
tous les cas on ne croit pas un barack
obama avec est en fin de mandat moon
allait rappeler mais il faut mener une
négociation très serrés vers autres
inconscients nos intérêts avec nos
propres lignes rouges très ferme un bon
type ou pathétique le coeur de l'europe
c'est la zone horreur
il faut que le coeur la zone euro soit
plus fort battre plus fort aujourd'hui
on a construit une romy est une union
monétaire
il nous manque encore l'union économique
et l'union politique c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi je propose un mise de
l'économie et des finances de la zone
euro qui serait membre de la commission
responsable devant le parlement européen
avec un budget pour la zone euro
vous avez présenté tout à l'heure les
prévisions de printemps de la commission
européenne les pressions
macroéconomiques apparemment à nouveau
la commission européenne voit la
croissance française un petit peu
moindre que celle qui est annoncée par
le gouvernement
comment pouvez vous expliquer cette
différence d'abord l'écart est faible
nous nous voyons 1,3 le clan français
voient 1,5
j'ajoute que nous n'avons pas intégré
dans nos chiffres les résultats du
premier trimestre qui sont plutôt un peu
meilleur que ce que corporelle nos
propres commissions et s'il y a un bonus
je dirais tant mieux de toute façon
cette croissance de l'économie française
reste légèrement inférieur à la moyenne
de la zone euro allaient de 6 %
pour nous cette année et demi pension
d'un prochain nous aurions un 8 7% pour
la france dont paris n'a pas à se vanter
il s'agit pas de se vanter ou pas dans
tes un peu de transactions
si on pose la question de savoir si ça
va mieux puisque c'est un peu du mal à
mode je dirai plus rien que ça va plutôt
mieux plutôt mieux parce que vous avez
d'une part la croissance qui est
maintenant reparti avec une consommation
intérieure qui tient bon avec un
investissement qui repart et on attend
sans doute le zeste de confiance
supplémentaire
vous avez des finances publiques dont la
situation s'améliore
on y reviendra j'imagine mais oui je
pense tout à fait jouable à condition
que les finances publiques soient
maîtrisées et que les engagements pris
soient respectés
je pense jouable de passer en deçà de 3%
en 2010 est enfin en fin de troisième
chose
troisième chose permettait que je le jeu
le jeu n'évoque pas ce que c'est tout à
fait important je crois que le chômage
devrait reculer en 2016 2004 pour cent
du pib à 10 2% du pib et donc je parle
de la dépression de la commission action
aujourd'hui dont une amélioration une
amélioration qui ne permettra pas de
résoudre tous les problèmes de la
société française notamment sur le
chômage
on attend sans doute plus il faut à
continuer mais enfin il compte des
bonnes nouvelles arrivent il ne faut pas
je pense les négliger
par ailleurs nous allons examiner en
plus tôt en 2016 le projet de budget
pour 2010 est de la france et nous
demanderons demanderont nous devons avec
beaucoup de fermeté que les engagements
qui ont été pris dans le pacte de
stabilité soit du tas que ce budget de
manière crédible montre quel est le
chemin qui nous amène en dessous de 3%
est ce que je dis ce n'est pas on va y
arriver je suis pas français à ce point
je ne suis pas schizophrène du doubs je
dis que si il y à des efforts je dis que
si les finances publiques sont sérieuses
je dis que si les dépenses
supplémentaires et qui avec dc et je dis
que si les baisses d'impôts éventualité
reprise en réplique n'a pas été
affirmatif sont financés dans ces
conditions la wii passé de 3,2 à en
dessous de 3%
c'est jouable et quand je m'exprime
ainsi recèle ce n'est pas ma parole
personnelle c'est la parole de la
commission
et quand je ne veux pas qu'il ya une
suspicion je ne suis pas une sorte comme
ça de le france est transposée à
bruxelles je suis le commissaire chargé
des affaires économiques et financières
par ailleurs français alors lui quand je
me lève c'est jouable
c'est ce que pour la commission ne pense
pas que certains ne pensent pas que
c'est fait elle pense que c'est jouable
si la france est sérieuse et nous
demanderons à l'air et les sérieuses
aujourd'hui quand vous étiez vous même
quand je compte quand je regarde le
chemin qui a mené leur ménage dans les
décisions là les dd quand on signe des
chèques là mais tous les jours encore
une fois ces chèques c'est que quand je
suis devenu misé finances j'avais dit à
mon prédécesseur commissaire la
commission fixe les fins nous fixons les
moyens je n'ai pas a expliqué à françois
hollande ou à michel sapin roi manuel
valls les choix qui doit le faire en
revanche ce que je dois faire moi c'est
le rappelait qu'il ya des règles
communes et que s'il ya des dépenses
supplémentaires
il devra y avoir des économies
correspondante s'il ya des baisses
d'impôt elles devront être financés
or de l'unité de la gauche il n'y a pas
d'accès au pouvoir la deuxième leçon
c'est qu'il faut aussi une cohérence
intellectuelle et idéologique qui
tiennent compte des leçons du réel car
sinon on se fracasse sur ce mur qui a
été le mur de l'argent à l'époque et qui
est le mur de la réalité
et chaque fois que la gauche a fait des
réformes qui sont restés mais chaque
fois que la gauche a voulu faire des
réformes qui se heurtait au réel à ce
moment là il était obligé de reculer et
donc il faut éviter de se renier ça
c'est la troisième leçon quand l'album
vite et on a besoin aujourd'hui on a
besoin c'est logique sociale démocrate
le réformisme qu'ils soient ancrés dans
le réel talent réformiste qui soit
également européen mais d'un réformisme
tous vos amis du parti socialiste sans
doute sans doute mais c'est aussi c'est
aussi renoncer aux valeurs de tours je
ne sais pas qui dit cela on va vous le
dire vous allez me dire parce que je
suis moi mais j'ai ce grand privilège
vous aime pas être tous les jours et des
mois le parti socialiste est ce que les
bombes avoir tous les fossoyeurs de ce
quinquennat
pierre moscovici août et non ceux qui
ils expriment des opinions ils ne votent
pas les textes qui est compliqué pour
une majorité
en même temps ils ne représentent pas
les l'immense majorité des socialistes
et des sociaux démocrates
ce quinquennat est un quinquennat donc
il appartient au président de la
république de démontrer qu'il a été
utile et puis ensuite on verra comment
cela se porte la campagne électorale
bien des prêts accusations il me semble
je m'exprime bien personnelles que les
explique les accusations de trahison ou
de renoncement sont sans fondement et
que ce n'est pas une façon au sein de la
gauche de mener le débat
donc vous ne comprenez pas que certains
puissent l art et du fait que françois
hollande se soit éloigné à ce point par
exemple du discours du bourget on cite
souvent de proposer parfois des des lois
finalement qui satisfont plus la droite
que la gauche l'a long travail par
exemple
au départ elle a quand même plus étaient
applaudis sur les bancs de la droite
applaudit comprenez moi moi là je suis
dans une position un peu inconfortable
jeu commissaire européen je ne peux me
faire ni le critique ni l'avocat
françois loos mais je n'ai pas envie je
n'ai pas envie et je ne peux pas je
dirais simplement ce que je crois sur le
plan des principes
je pense que une gauche de
transformation qu'une grotte de réformes
qu une gauche dure et elle qu'une gauche
européenne qu'une gauche
sociale-démocrate que nous
rénové et bien l'avenir pour cette
famille politique qu'elle a besoin de
rester elle même qu'elle a besoin casser
authentique qu'elle vous en restez
fidèle à ses valeurs qu'elle a besoin
aussi de tenir compte du réel est-ce que
cela s'est passé pendant ces cinq ans je
pense que honnêtement il ya eu une
tentative sincère pour le faire avec de
vrais résultats avec de vraies réformes
qu'il ya sans doute eu aussi des choses
qui n'ont pas fonctionné qu'il faut
faire ce diplôme un prémice à donner un
certain nombre d'exemples pour en donner
d'autres prénoms en a plus qu'on a
randonné mais ce n'est pas à moi de le
faire encore une fois mais ce qu'on a à
l'heure du bilan c'est vrai que manuel
valls a pointé un certain nombre
d'erreurs notre naissance avait une
campagne électorale est proche
c'est ce moment privilégié où il ya
cette rencontre avec le pays ce grand
débat où il ya d'une part le bilan et
les nécessaires et nous est fait le chef
de l'état et la majorité c'est
l'opposition mais aussi par le chef
d'état est pas la majorité lui même et
je crois comprendre que françois
hollande réfléchit aussi lui-même ce qui
a fonctionné et ce qui n'est pas mal
fonctionné
et puis il ya aussi et c'est une
deuxième dimension qui est essentiel
c'est la dimension du projet avant même
la fin du quinquennat ou à la fin du
quinquennat
je ne n'ai pas le sens la sensation
quand je raconte françois hollande de
trouver quelqu'un need a battu il ne
l'est pas ça nous sommes combatifs il
l'a toujours été
il sait ce que c'est que la politique il
a de l'expérience et du métier il a
beaucoup de sang froid
mais ce n'est pas non plus un homme
auteur satisfait je pense qu'il est
aussi capable lui même de se dire voilà
ça ça fonctionne et ça ça n'a pas
fonctionné
et s'il était candidat il s'est sans
doute que le projet devrait être à la
fois le prolongement de ce qui a été
fait et aussi sans doute un peu
différent ça c'est la propre le propre
d'un bon politique et je pense que en
toute hypothèse qu'on peut lui faire
beaucoup de critiques elle va nous
amener des années l'état mais sur les
hommes qui se prépare non je dis ça je
dis simplement que les télés monde
impression j'ai pas dû seulement hier
c'est un homme très chaud chaud là que
je connais bien depuis 35 ans j'ai été
effectivement le directeur de sa
campagne présidentielle
je ne suis pas son porte parole je ne
sais pas quelles sont ces attentions
mais mon sentiment c'est que c'est un
homme qui est combatif qui est fier de
ce qu'il a fait et qui est aussi un
homme lucide et qu'ils seront candidats
c'est pas ça vous savez dans tous les
cas vous dites on verra comment les
choses tournent pendant la campagne
électorale
je voudrais une autre impression plus
aisés comme ça on est sous la vème
république
la logique elle s'est toujours appliqué
et que le président n'aurait plus que
sortant se représente à la fois pour
défendre son bilan et pour porter un
nouveau projet ça ne marche pas toujours
pas toujours été réélu beaucoup évolué
notamment à cause du quinquennat je je
je je je pense que la logique tout de
même c'est aussi de se donner du temps
et que justement parce qu'il ya le
quinquennal quinquennat pourquoi at il
été fait on pouvait se dire deux fois
sept ans c'est trop et d'ailleurs à part
françois mitterrand personnes a fait
deux fois 7 ans et les dernières années
80 les années compliquées et donc on
sait ni le quinquennat pourquoi pas ce
qu'on peut faire deux fois cinq ans
c'est en gros le rythme qui existe dans
nos démocraties donc l'existant du
quinquennat va plutôt renforcé l'idée de
deux candidatures d'un homme à la
présidence de la république le s'est
toujours passé le président encore une
fois je ne fais qu'une observation fait
l'historique me paraît cohérente le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
la coalition elle peut être obligé si
d'aventuré madame le pen était au 2e
tour en 2010 est certes un sondage
beaucoup de sondages en réalité le
disent alors à ce moment il serait
compliqué pour ceux qui auraient élu un
président deuxième tour de dire on
s'ignore
mais ce serait le résultat de l'élection
et ce serait forcément un combat ça ne
peut pas c'est une confusion qui précède
l'élection
c'est en tout cas une hypothèse mageia
pâquis emmanuel macron manuel valls dit
aussi un peu les mêmes choses que son
ministre que j'aime là je ne veux pas
les départager mais ils ne nous disent
pas tout à fait la même chose jean
christophe cambadélis ne disent pas la
même chose ils disent pas la même chose
dans l'es10 pas la même chose parce que
lundi voilà ni droite ni gauche ont fait
quelque chose avant c'est le sens de son
mouvement
l'audi je suis de gauche et je peux être
amené à travailler avec d'autres dans le
cas d'une coalition ce qui est déjà plus
classique
nous verrons canalis a dépassé aussi les
particuliers en toute hypothèse
ce qui est important et ça c'est la
position constante c'est que la gauche
rénove
il ya évidemment une insatisfaction par
rapport à la gauche en france il ya
besoin de modernisation
il ya besoin de tes origines au journal
il ya besoin de théoriser ce qui a été
fait il ya un besoin de conceptualiser
il ya besoin d'avancer dans la gauche
par rapport à l'europe d'être enfin
complètement européen et de construire
également une europe qui soit davantage
marqué par les idées de la gauche de
faire des propositions socio démocrates
mais j'y travaille moi avec martin
schulz le président du parlement
européen avec matteo renzi et donc voilà
je crois plus que notre avenir c'est la
modernisation de la gauche
la refondation de la gauche la
rénovation de la gauche que
l'affadissement la gauche ou la fin de
la gauche c'est françois hollande
qu'elle incarne ça on verra je sais pas
je sais c'est pas moi de le dire
je dis simplement que quand je vois le
président la république je vois un homme
combatif